this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is supported by patreon who
actually got this episode four days
early and they got an extra 10 minutes
of Mike and I rambling at the start plus
the show is completely ad free on
patreon if you want to support this very
independent show which has been
declining sponsorships for years now
check us out on patreon where you also
get early access to episodes and
completely unedited episodes you can
find the link in the description
otherwise enjoy the show uh so I've been
playing a lot of Starfield it is my life
right now is sleep work Starfield that's
all I want to do and I'm cool with it I
put in over 100 hours having a great
time and so because it's all I'm playing
I'm also making a lot of content about
it like I've been making I noticed that
I got served a lot of you're making like
two shorts today yeah yeah so I was
doing it because there's so much cool
stuff to see but also because people are
statistically enjoying those so much
that I was like then I'll keep making
them until I stop playing Starfield so
and they're a really really easy to make
um so I've been making a ton of those
also just because there's so much cool
user generated stuff around Starfield
it's so neat um I love one again that
gets me interested like the ships the
people are making and stuff like
multiple kits and stuff I just want to
play with those tools that I'm really
bad at it um but because I'm making so
much Darfield content I'm
seeing a lot of Starfield conversation
and people have a lot of opinions on it
of course as they do with the video game
but there are a few questions that I had
been like okay let me ask Mike about
this one of them I actually called out
in a short which is the first one that I
wanted to ask you
um yeah I mean I know the answers to
some of these but it's like let's ask
the program and just you know make it
extra valid the first one was uh you
don't need me you don't need me to
validate your views I'm gonna well I
answered a question for one person and
they were like I wanted to ask Mike and
I was like I just gave you the answer
but is that seriously what happened is
that what we're doing well I I also work
in good film it but it's fine okay allow
me to use way more pretentious words to
say exactly what I bet you said thank
you
um the first if not conferred so it's
going to be the same go on yeah well I
also don't mind being like listen we can
use Mike and be like oh the programmer
said it even though programmers don't
program half this stuff but it's again
it's [__] program stuff exactly
that's the biggest thing I don't [__]
know anything yeah that's my big
disclaimer before you ask me any
questions it's all just opinions uh they
use their own engine as well like it's
yeah we ultimately we have no idea the
same they've been using have they been
in the same engine basically like Skyrim
very long time
really I think so but uh they updated
yeah I mean not even the look it's like
clearly their systems are the same right
like it's just that's that engine is
also that it's not just visuals which
again I know you know but other people
don't know
um okay so the first question which is
one that like I'm really not sure about
um I could make some guesses but there
are no mini maps in the main cities
which you know you haven't played the
game but you go to a city they're pretty
large they have stores whatever
um and there will be some signage saying
like this way to the commercial District
but then even when you go to the
commercial District you might forget
where the UC Vanguard is or they're not
even in the commercial District that oh
no they are
um you you basically like don't know
where exactly the stores are you just
have to go to the districts and
physically find them
um I strongly dislike this I think some
people like it because like you have to
get used to the setting and I am over
time but it's still like I played 100
hours I still don't know where they're
going where I'm going
um why do you think
even outside of a programming answer you
would not put a mini map
in a city that players are going to go
to frequently and need to be able to
access
various locations
so I had a look at some videos I'm
writing saying that there is like there
is like a pause menu map but it's
basically like a field of gray dots and
then just like the icons
no it's not useful or like directions it
will tell you like Compass points and
stuff but it won't
so
I think there's a design explanation a
code explanation
so the design explanation is exactly
what you just said that it's about
presence it's about when making you
learn a learn a city and interact with
the signage and stuff I there's a
there's a there's a school of thought on
game design which is basically all game
design is just about confusing the
obvious answer so basically you know you
could absolutely play a version of
Starfield where it just comes up with a
list of all the locations you can go to
and you click on a location and you're
there and then you click on this the
thing you want to buy in the shop you're
in and you get that and there's no
friction at all you have infinite money
it's just games are friction games are
creating a bunch of obstacles for you to
overcome on your path to otherwise it
would be going to Amazon to buy
something right it's it's designed to be
frictiony and you could make the design
argument that if they gave you a map and
gave you all of that information would
you have a sense of would you be paying
as much attention to the environment
around you and and getting a sense of
that presence of that space it's
something we we're having a lot of
conversations around with some stuff
we're doing
we really want to create this sense of
presence and how do you do that and how
how do you make the player develop that
for themselves
um so it's a that's that's the design
conversation that I can imagine there's
a second there as well in terms of
design which is that when you go to any
of the planets that don't have cities
for example uh there can't really be a
minimap because they're procedurally
generated and I think it's probably the
code reason well I think that's probably
very confusing to players even like
without talking about code of like what
has a mini map and what doesn't and then
players who played the city and become
accustomed to minimaps would be like
where is my mini map and think there's
something broken and like that's also a
big part of Game Dev that you know has
become more and more obvious to me is
people will miss things and you have to
pick and choose when to reinforce the
things and make sure nobody also the
standards yeah exactly and then the
consistency of the standards so like
yeah so that was where I was going to go
with the code thing it's the code thing
as you say absolutely with procedurally
generated environments it's incredibly
it would be incredibly difficult to make
a map screen you could do it still like
there's procedurally generate the map
screen at the same time
it doesn't need to be you can do kind of
you can use you can do like a render
texture there's a lot of games that when
they've got like um they'll have a mini
map but that's Minecraft does it
basically
yeah it's totally doable like we did it
in um in our game volume
um years ago we had like use generated
levels so you could make a level but
then when you're on the main menu there
was like an image of the level like a
top-down map of the level showing before
you went into them and that was just we
basically just did a render season
basically it's literally you just make a
camera
put it up above the level orthographic
perspective take a photo save that photo
and now you've got that photo oh that's
cool so there are
there are ways of doing that but there's
lots of reasons why that would be tricky
or messy or not hit the standard and I
think that's the biggest thing is
um the expectations of consistency that
you they exist in a in a commercial
product and this is why mod teams and I
was watching a video about the minimap
thing and the the guy showed like
there's some mods that you can just like
get a map for whatever that means yeah
so gamedashmaps.com has a bunch of maps
for all of the cities
um and someone's made a mod where that
map will be on a billboard which I think
is an awesome solution like that's it's
such a good idea because it's clearly
that works a billboard so billboard
makes sense and you've got the Lord
you're in you're in the store but also
there's a story reason like someone put
a billboard up with a map on the
tourists
they're tourists because there's there's
there's infrastructure is being built
here so they built that the the the
point I was going to is that like with
um
for players if you're inconsistent that
can look Messier yeah um and again this
is actually something I can't I can't
talk about what it is but we're talking
about in relation to our next project is
there is there is the thing when you're
making a video game not having something
I'm just gonna let me think of an
example here from like
if if Mario had no music like a like a
Mario manes had no music
you'd have you wouldn't care you you
you'd notice but it would be fine if
Mario has all the music you're like oh
yeah this is beautiful wonderful music
and that's the universe we live in and
that's great if Mario had music in one
level and then not in the rest that
would be the worst outcome because you'd
be annoyed by it I'd be like they didn't
finish this game yeah it stops feeling
like a creative choice and becomes oh
they they didn't do a good job they
messed up and that's where we're seeing
something being taken away
it's more you're kind of you yeah you're
you're aware of the issue if it's if
you're ordering a takeaway on an app and
you and you order like a couple of sides
and one of the sides doesn't show up
that is so much more annoying than if
you just forgot to order that extra side
you wanted right like it's that loss and
there's a name for it in getting um in
gambling and economics I can't remember
the name of it but like the the sense of
loss the sense of I'm missing out on
something here so that's possibly the
argument is if they ran into like a
technical problem which prevented them
from doing map screens everywhere then
there's probably a pretty decent
argument that well we should do them
nowhere then because then then no one
will notice they're not there and of
course that seems like that was a wrong
argument maybe and maybe they would do
something with a patch to kind of add
that back in but there's definitely the
argument with design of like
not pointing out to the player what
they're missing not not giving them
something
not adding a mechanic here that you
can't do everywhere because if you do it
here and not there people will be pissed
off right and I I can kind of I
definitely made choices like that on
previous games like that's definitely
something you have to do
um but yeah it's it's
well it's it's one of those ones where
it could also honestly just be something
as simple as scope one of the
interesting things you think that like
something like I assume a minimap is
relatively simple you think that's a
scoping issue
it's it's not necessarily in and of
itself but it's a dependency in scope
issues so if the last it would be the
last thing you do yeah so if you're
making if you're making little tweaks to
your levels and making different
environments and oh we want to make that
or in this area look a bit better
because we you know we've got a little
time to do that or we want to add a room
here because play testing shows that
players need to blah blah blah
if you do that you have to re-render
right all of your map screens assuming
it's an image but it and it definitely
is in this case
um they would they would basically
there's a dependency there of like
basically and this is this is a lot of
game development this is the boring
stuff no one ever wants to hear about
but like it's all a series of
dependencies so if you know rendering a
map and making sure an artist looks it
and goes yeah that looks fine if that
takes an hour
and you've got a hundred locations
that's a hundred hours and you can't
start that job until you've locked all
of your environmental art and your
environment artists are crunching to try
and get this thing gold right on the
deadline but you've got 100 hours of
this
I could totally see a decision where you
go we're running late things are things
are where they are my artists are
exhausted I've not got 100 hours to put
into this map screen stuff let's get it
out in our first update and it's a nice
quality of life feature that players
will thank us for I could see that as
well I'm not saying that's what happens
that's a train of that's like we did it
so like with um in much smaller scale
but Solitaire conspiracy when we
launched it you you selected your next
mission from like a list of missions and
we always wanted to have like a cool spy
map but it just was one of those things
where we were doing other things and we
just didn't have time to get that done
even though that would have been in
itself a pretty quick job what would
matter
oh first off that conspiracy it's just
the main menu when you go in it's like a
a cool cool CG map of the world with
like little icons one of which if you
click on comes oh yeah I was gonna say
the map is already there
Oh you mean it wasn't there at launch
right sorry I was like okay
[Applause]
just it was just literally came up with
like menu options of button boring
buttons of missions which made the game
feel a lot smaller a lot less
interesting
um and it was one of those things of
like we're not going to get this done
for launch but that's something we can
hit with like a month after release get
that rolling now and then that's a nice
quality of life feature and players will
be you know they won't people aren't
going to like review bomb the game
because there's not a mapping in but
they'll be grateful a month later for
like a cool quality of life feature so
you do make those kind of decisions when
you're launching a game in the modern
world where you know you're going to be
able to do a Post Release update if it
is it is there is always
there's always that weighing up like
every single bug database for every
single game ever made still has bugs in
it and still has features that they
didn't get in like no no game is
complete you always you always ship a
game before it's done because you have
to and those things may have slid I can
absolutely see that being a decision
like that uh games that don't come out
like that's literally exactly yeah yeah
um and I also think like
potentially controversial but Bethesda
lives in a really unique place where
they support the modern community so
much and I wonder how often it comes up
in conversation for them we're like well
someone will mod that like that
obviously you shouldn't depend on your
community to do stuff like that but
they're so supportive of it and
encouraging of it that I wonder if they
ever
actually Factor it in like oh they'll do
it as a mod because they may be
like bgs specifically
um may be the most
well known it is for AAA for sure like
studio for mod support
yeah like it's hard to think of other
people that have like historically
always been that welcoming of mods and
that's why somebody already modding the
map in is awesome
um I initially had also assumed there's
this bug that seemingly everybody has
which is like so minor uh where your
player will look to the left if you're
running in third person they just like
their head just spins it away and it
happens to almost everybody
um and I had assumed I was like well
they probably haven't fixed it because
it's hard to fix like there's probably
some weird thing with that particular
behavior that has made that like like
changing it will break something else
like maybe it's like you're looking
towards your objective marker and the
way that they've literally programmed
the objective marker is like there's
some there's some weird [__] that's made
that happen but a model fixed it
immediately and I was like oh
maybe that was one of the ones that they
were like it's not a big deal they just
I wonder that's what you're describing
again like all of these all of these
things I'm saying are completely
ignorant uninformed I'd love to look at
them the game seems so dense that's what
makes it so interesting it's like what
but that's one of those things where
like
that wouldn't have been that because
it's a because it's related to like
camera look and move if that was in any
way frequent they would have fixed it
because that would be immediately would
shoot up the list like a bit be a high B
kind of book ass bug eight class bug is
like a crash or whatever but B is like
it would sit there
so that makes me wonder if there's some
weird Quirk of how they were playing the
game that's the kind of bug you get when
the entire Dev team is using keyboard
and mouse and not controller or vice
versa or where everyone on the team is
using a good controller because they've
been given like brand new Xbox
controllers QA is actually a job to play
in as many ways totally right like and I
think it does maybe happen if you're
like looking at somewhere and then you
like go into third person mode like it's
not if you're in first person your
camera won't shift it's just the player
character will look left while you're
running forward the other possibility
there especially is bug fixing and again
this is something you know this well but
like bug fixing is not a linear process
so it's entirely possible there was a
bigger camera bug that they fixed a week
before release
high-fived didn't realize they created
this as like a result every bug
generates two more bugs that's that's
kind of yeah but just on that point
about uh QA I know this wasn't I know
you weren't like knocking QA from
missing stuff but like this is one one
of the reasons a good example of this is
every game Studio I've ever worked at
now the game Studio I own has the policy
of the last six months of release I
don't care how good your podcasts are or
how sick the sound of the soundtrack to
the game you are you have to play with
the audio on because most games teams
when when you're playing the same game
every day to work on it you turn you
mute it you're not listening to the
audience no I didn't do that we when I
was playing through Ragnarok it listen
every time but I guess that's because
for now you probably weren't playing it
straight like no I wasn't playing as
much as QA it's also that I needed to
hear the lines
so there you go but most programmers say
who are working on like gameplay uh
gameplay code for the game will play the
game muted and be listening to their own
music or podcasts or whatever while
they're working fair enough yeah my
point is like towards the end of
development you get the whole team to
put their audio on and you find a bunch
of audio bugs every single time yeah
because people are finally listening to
the game and audio bugs are playing for
two hours at a time because like there's
so much stuff where
like it's just games are terrifying is
All I'm gonna say like seeing stuff in
in engine and then being like okay well
that will trigger this line but then we
have to be careful of when that line
gets triggered and like
there's just so much of that like even
writing a script for a video game is
like not as simple as it seems because
so much of it is well that this will get
triggered here and then but there's not
enough space for that to not trigger
over the top of that so you have to be
careful about that line like it's just
so much and I think that's why AudioBox
is so common in a way that I didn't
realize it's just it's getting audio to
play in the right places where you want
it to it's like a whole separate video
game in and of itself like it's not like
lying so compounded so specific
yeah they take they can they can take
like there's literally there's I think
it might even still be in the game
there's an audio bugging Thomas Was
Alone that only happens if you've had
the game running for three hours so like
no one found it some people feel like
we're not meant to be making video games
like as also an atheist it's like God
was like none of you are supposed to be
doing this and then we're like let's
make it let's make it go anyway right
he's like absolutely not that's why bad
things happen in the world is because
that's every bad thing in the world is
called I like that it's a lot uh and
there are a lot of problems
um yeah so the the left look is one
question oh yeah go ahead what sorry I
should say that was oh yeah well that we
elaborated into the also why did they
look left but again someone fixed really
quickly it was I don't know it's really
hard I need to read the notes on that
that's what I was thinking was what are
the notes that they like how did they
fix it what was the actual issue because
sometimes I feel like modders can use
tools that the dev team doesn't have
access to as well like that you
literally aren't able to use because
it's like the company doesn't own the
software or whatever like there's a
million reasons it's that they can do
stuff that the dev teams can't uh which
is a thing that I love about Bethesda
for the record I think the mod support
is really cool though obviously you
shouldn't depend on your audience to do
it but I'd be interested to ask somebody
there if they do or do not do that or
how often it comes up in meetings like I
don't I don't know I can see it coming
up for like for edge cases for like we
know 10 of our audience is going to want
this feature yeah I wouldn't have
thought in those kind of conversations
no not for bug fixes but I bet for like
we think there's going to be a subset of
the audience who wants X are they on PC
yes okay well then probably if there's
enough of them there'll be a mod that I
I bet it's not lent on but I bet it's
something that factors in to some degree
but but I think I see someone like
literally how next time I see Todd like
excuse me how often do you bring this up
hey Todd
um I think the last time that I saw him
I was parading him and Phil about
holding uh a white series X
and uh nobody said anything and I was of
the assumption that that meant that I
was like they were gonna announce it
um but they did announce that Starfield
Xbox rap which I actually just saw in
person yesterday so it's the first time
there's been a console wrap because
usually I hate them like no matter what
I hate them because they're stickers
they often look kind of cheap it's just
that I think it's more of a me problem
than that even they're a really good
high quality ones now but I always put
them off slightly off center and I have
like a very very very minor I don't even
like calling it up but a minor OCD with
[__] like that where it will like drive
me insane forever and I will have to rip
it off so I like can't yeah stickles
stickers I can't do it it had but so
that the the wrap they made for
Starfield is like
like plastic it's not a sticker it's
like a hard case that also kind of it
almost magnetizes yeah it actually looks
it looks pretty cool yeah they did a
good job
um okay so I'm gonna ask you the third
question second because I think it's
easier than the second question uh how
difficult is object permanence in a game
like this which is for example
if I leave a sandwich on my ship I go
play 15 hours of the video game I've
swapped out my ship I swapped back to
the first ship that sandwich is still
Fair
um and in Starfield this is pretty
extensive uh you know I spawned I tried
to spawn a hundred thousand potatoes in
a room
um people are loving the potatoes I've
seen a lot of potatoes I'm gonna do some
more potato stuff actually I was gonna
try and spawn some in zero juice it's
really fun and it's a really fun game to
play with because you do have you
tools I think that's why I'm like still
so in love with playing it
um you have a lot of tools at your
disposal to be like I wonder what
happens if this and that's like some of
my favorite video games experience and
it saves all of that so you spawn all
those potatoes you go somewhere else you
come back they're still there correct
those potatoes will still be good um so
that's my question is how difficult is
that and why what do you think is the
design decision decision
having object permanence it's like I
well they're designed to say that's easy
the design decision is so you'll make a
bunch of videos about thousands of
potatoes because there was enough videos
of that in like was it Oblivion where
there were people like putting they did
potatoes on people's heads yeah I mean
it was so they even even when I did the
potato video it was I I said it in in
the video I was inspired by somebody who
um did it on Reddit which was yeah like
they spawned a bunch of potatoes in
their ship but it turns out that like
even after that like I was like so many
people like oh this person did it in
this place and this person like so many
people had been doing it just to see
what happens but people are still
watching it because it's very fun every
time and that's the design reason so
that's why they did this they knew
people would do that I feel like there's
someone to it than that I feel like the
inventory in the game is like such a big
thing and it's got to be like you know
especially for a crafting game if you
have a bunch of [__] and you want to
dump it somewhere
yeah and then you want to go back and
get those resources like it I feel like
it just ties into the design oh that's a
nice win yeah it can't just I bet it's
not but it
so so the reason I think it's probably
not necessarily marketing but like this
is a thing we know players have fun with
the reason I would say it's more likely
to be that than that they actually want
you as a player to use to do object
permanence mechanics right yeah so you
have an inventory right your ship has an
inventory you have for everybody they're
just being so loud today
oh that's good maybe it won't be picked
up he's like chewing on this pig toy
that has this sound effect that actually
sounds like a pig it's actually pretty
deep
like it actually is
it's very low register though so I think
it's right it's like the only squeaky
toy that I have that like is low
registered yeah it's kind of cool sorry
um
because they think players want to
interact with the object permanence
mechanically which realistically no they
don't I don't think I ever need and also
they technically couldn't so that's the
interesting element here is so the
answer to the question of how hard this
is code wise
I'm I'm getting bad I'm getting I'm much
better than I was weaker
um the uh
so so is it like how hard is it to save
where an object is in the world not very
hard at all really you literally have to
save its physical location what it is
all that stuff that's fine that's not
something
that's the problem right the problem is
like so many things in game development
is
um exponential multiplication so if you
have one potato
I don't know how much data it takes to
store the position of a potato
a few bits like not much like genuinely
a tiny amount of data to save that but
as you
put 10 000 in your spaceship
um that will hit a number and there is
going to be a limit on your save data
for the game right uh because they're
going to be saving lots of other stuff
there obviously so there is going to be
under the hood and I I'm sure someone
online will find it at some point there
will be a limit there'll be like
literally you can save the physical
location and 50 000 objects and then
once you get to that 50 0001 object that
first object is going to get forgotten
so I think that that what actually
happens which maybe what you're saying
is the solution
um
is that the game will crash so once you
have really are they donated for that
once you have a certain amount uh uh and
you can keep putting potatoes there um
the game will crash and I know that some
people have had corrupted save files
because now they can't load the save
because it repeatedly crashes so I think
your solution better one
and that is the standard so like I
remember I remember this this is this is
the difference between the console
Generations I remember playing GTA 3 as
a teenager
and Banger of a video again
yeah well absolutely
convince my yeah I managed to convince
my mum that the ratings on games were
difficulty rather than
wrong oh boy totally worked I was like I
am pretty Advanced at school mum I think
I can handle that's amazing I was I was
15. play GTA
aside but I'm sure I brought this up
before as well but I think about it a
lot play GTA 3 Vice City and and San
Andreas they came as like a package the
triple box yeah which I love the look of
it was so well packaged um on the
original Xbox I think I played them and
I whatever year that came out is when I
played those games my parents didn't
question it
like I'm always like yeah yeah whenever
I have friends now I'll be like because
I played uh Starfield when I played it
um Mike Flanagan let me use his PR his
theater home theater setup that he calls
the flanaplex Wednesday that's amazing
what's his new show uh are you asking
personally because it's struck yeah just
for your personal advice October 12th
yeah
it's such an uncomfortable situation
um I wish I could talk about it
constantly I want to do trailer
reactions all of it but it's like got a
spot to strike a sports strike of course
oh so excited about it but um they had
two kids there and I was like yeah this
game's not I think this game's fine
they're probably like 12 maybe and one
of them's a little bit younger and I was
like this is gonna be fine it's totally
it's not gonna be a problem
and then they happen to come in at the
one part where I'm shooting a bunch of
pirates in the face and I was like [__]
but I feel it's it's such a weird thing
to think about it's like I'm a extremely
non-violent person and that that was
always the concern it's like oh it
didn't seem to have an effect on me as a
12 year old but I can't guarantee that
for everyone else
don't know how that I
no and Jack that's what Jack Thompson
was fighting for was to so that we were
not corrupted and we totally wanted but
the the uh the the thing with GTA 3 that
I remember being really annoyed by as a
kid was if you stole a car
and then got out of it and then you
stole another car and drove away and
came back your first car was gone unless
you kept line of sight on the first car
I think or it was two cars there was
there was some very small limit of
memory which was why you have the garage
so you could park a car in and save it
yeah but I never wanted to do that
because I was like well did you just
know where the car was I just left it
there because obviously I was I'm
kidding now the clubs came in that's
exactly there you go so it works and and
that was the thing and I remember as
well with like blown up cars like I'd
set up these Domino dominoes like 20
cars to explode and then you'd look away
and then you turn back and all the cars
would be gone and we're past that point
now and you know we can do tens of
thousands of objects but there is always
going to be a physical limit to that
because you are there is it is Data
there is still anything the player does
or moves is going to have a limit memory
is extremely limiting just for all
aspects of game development like even
memory and save data yeah yeah so what
you're doing live and also what's being
stored both of those things will have
their own limits and and this comes back
to the uh and this is why more games
don't do persistence is
if I can only achieve a hundred
persistent objects how pissed off are
you going to be when I delete that 101st
object and as a designer do I even open
the door to that criticism do I just
make it so it's not persistent and just
avoid frustrating you when I'm healing
it sounds like here they knew people are
going to mess around so they put that
limit pretty high but it is and has that
problem well
it's only happening for people
realistically who are using console
commands because how are you going to
get a hundred thousand potatoes in a
room
so it's not like space plan where you
can have like a billion potatoes I mean
you'd have to find them like if you
wanted to spend your time in Starfield
finding every potato in the game and
storing them in a room you could but
like so if you hack the game then it's
kind of your which is what I which is
what I did and I assume everybody else
did is use console commands um which you
know again Bethesda very openly support
from day one like I love that too that
you can choose console commands whenever
you want to but like you're kind of
opting in but you're on your own yes and
I think that that's totally fine like
it's um massive fun with it I only know
of one person who's safe I'll go
corrupted that did not happen to me mine
was fine it did crash the game it
totally wouldn't be shock I wouldn't be
shocked if they quietly added a fix for
that if they know players are doing it
and they're making fun content yeah they
may well just because you do that a lot
like you definitely
um you definitely create bug fixes for
theoretical bugs all the time yeah like
there's you don't you don't make a game
that's completely broken and then fix it
you try and fix those kind of outcomes
so putting a soft limit on that would
make sense and I wouldn't be surprised
if they had that the problem
so like it's tough to make a soft limit
for how many potatoes you can spawn
because it would be different for every
player depending on their CPU
you can do it proportionally you can you
can go okay how much CPU I have to play
with yeah that's cool I don't know you
could do that sorry no of course you can
that was rude yeah you could absolutely
yeah you can absolutely kind of you can
absolutely like detect how the
computer's getting along with stuff
um and get those kind of value I also
feel like it's a tough one because then
people are going to be like but I want
to break it I don't know what the
solution to that is because I think
they've they've let us [__] around and
find out and I think that's kind of what
people want
and honestly where's the harm like
people you know yeah people people know
the rest there are also it does also
split into which is a thing that I
really like when you play with the
console commands it splits into two save
files so you have what will now be
called a modded save file and a separate
save file um like a base save file so it
splits them because you can't own
achievements on the one that you've been
using console commands on though someone
already modded that so you still can but
um it's not destructive you can go back
you could always load your previous save
file I I would imagine it's not going to
corrupt that it would just corrupt the
bot it's safe which is is effectively a
fix for that particular issue but yeah I
think it's an interesting probably right
that the object permanence is something
that is there for fun
um more so than it's there because they
saw a play test to pick up a potato and
put it on a shelf and laugh for like
five it's also a thing where like you
know how you pick up something in a
Bethesda game and they like elaborately
drag it like if you pick if you hold
something and then the drag is just like
this stupid looking and I'm like they
know that looks stupid it's there
because it's fun like it's not there
because you could put an animation of
somebody carrying something over their
shoulder and waddling off but that's not
as funny as me accidentally getting a
man stuck on a staircase trying to drag
him downstairs like it's just more fun
but it's a fun thing for people who who
aren't necessarily into kind of coding
or whatever to kind of keep an eye on in
games is where those limits are
intentionally placed and to in a way
that doesn't piss you off because
there's like there's an Artistry to that
like things like having capacity on
inventory you don't have an infinite
inventory you have a limited inventory
that means they know exactly how much
data they need to save for your
inventory and they can kind of plan
around that so there's structural a lot
of the walls and limitations in games
are structurally there to technical
reasons as much as game design reasons
and I think there's once you see through
the Matrix with that stuff you can have
seek see the hand of the the designer
encoder kind of making sure that your
game runs everything is always thought
out like yeah someone always thought of
everything and I think um
like inventory Management's obviously
obviously a huge thing with this game
and like I just feel like there's so
many memory resource allocation things
in terms of so I flew to Pluto took you
seven hours to get there
um just to see what would happen right
and Pluto was effectively
just a hollow sphere with a JPEG mapped
around the outside uh that so are you
the person who did the seven hour video
because I'm sure
someone brought out someone's like I I
saw a video where someone spent like
seven hours flying through yeah because
because the next question you're gonna
ask I actually asked some people on my
team earlier because I was like I think
I know the answer to this because I just
bounced off of you guys and one of them
said well I watched a video from someone
who did something else I was like I
think that was awesome so this is
perfect so this is this is yeah
um and yeah my point just being when I
got there it was just a hollow sphere
with the jpeg map but sure
it's still a decision that makes a ton
of sense because
realistically like people can I wasn't
disappointed by that at all I was just
curious about what would be there and I
wanted to see what was going to happen
when I got there so a few people are
going to do that
um the one that I'm really curious about
because I've tried it as well and we'll
have a video up about it as well once I
edit it together and I want to try one
more thing
I don't know if you can fly to any of
the Suns or the stars
um and I've tried uh as many times as
possible I put a bunch of time into it I
used console commands so I increased
player speed and in-game time I was
gonna say the distance is so big the
distance is enormous so I tried
I tried um that's a football I did 10
000 hours I remember this from school
obviously using console commands with
player time sped up and seemingly made
it a little bit closer but barely
um like not really at all so I I don't
know if you can get there the only thing
I haven't tried is using uh no clip
camera but even that is not gonna move
fast enough for me did you do console
commands for your seven hour video it
wouldn't have taken seven hours that's
fasten like that's the part that's
interesting to me because this is again
it's a common problem if I don't want
you to be able to actually get to Pluto
but I want you to feel like you're
physically moving around Pluto I put in
a curve I go I basically exponentially I
apply so much friction to you that
you'll eventually hear a wall so I make
it the when you're spawned you can move
really fast and then as you get closer
to Pluto your speed has not done that at
all they've not done so not even because
that would hit a wall and you would be
static I ran into Pluto but at the start
I had incorrectly assumed and said this
publicly and that's part of why I wanted
to correct my mistake
um and typically I also asked four other
reviewers about it before I said it and
everyone had to shoot into the same
thing
you don't feel like you're moving in
space at all
so I had said you're not actually moving
in space you can't get any closer to
these planets again this is incorrect
um you're just in a sky boxing space not
moving and it it feels like you're not
moving
closer to anything ever nothing ever
gets bigger well it should like
physically it should because you're so
distant from the objects correct like if
you if you step to the left the clouds
don't look like they moved that is the
correct thing to do uh and and so it
took seven hours and then even then in
the city why do they bother doing it
that's what I don't understand is why is
it not static then well that's wild so
okay sorry to reiterate the video for
anyone who's seen it they the planets
also have orbit which I thought was
incredible like that blew my mind so I
had to repeatedly readjust to try to get
to Pluto because it would slip out of my
view even if I was directly ahead it
would repeatedly like duck out of frame
and so I try to account for the orbit as
much as I could but I didn't want to be
facing like fully the opposite direction
in case the orbit wasn't like a direct
exact path so I had to wake up every 30
minutes to readjust to make sure I was
aiming at Pluto and I try to do it to
Jupiter never got any closer to Jupiter
so I don't even know if I could do that
I never got any closer and it moved way
too fast because I wanted to see what
the Rings would look like if I got close
again not sure if you can or not it's so
far away
um but this is the question by the way
you have to ask Todd yeah because what
what you've discovered here is
fascinating as well like do you know do
you want a floating Point error is no
but yeah super quick oh sorry the reason
that I suspect that the jpeg sphere
exists at all is so that when you're on
a planet's surface the other planets
have orbit
that is very confusing to me though
because they shouldn't exist in those
two separate instances why would they no
this is weird and the reason it's weird
is floating Point errors so
flow pointers or arrows are amazing so
basically this is one of those this is
one of those things that sounds like I'm
making up but it's genuinely true so
numbers don't work the way you think
they do uh what in computers you need to
start with that I'm already bad at math
in
so because compute because because
computers are just a series of sums
right they're just every whenever you're
running around the video game everything
that's happening the physics the render
everything is just lots and lots of
songs so one of the ways that we make
those sums more efficient is we don't
calculate the world to a billion decimal
places
right so there's it's not numbers are
not
infinite in the way they are in the real
world where any number you could divide
by a billion billion billion trillion
zillion and it would still keep going
right
so what that means is
um the two things that can go really
wrong in a computer game from a spatial
point of view
are very very small things and very very
big things
um because essentially the the numbers
underlying them are abstracted and kind
of guessed out there's kind of there's
lots of rounding and and guesswork
involved which means in most game
engines if you were to travel five miles
in the virtual world over there
you literally would see and it's it's
for every program in the world has done
this at some point for fun because we're
really cool people you would see your
character mesh would start glitching
like everything starts wobbling and and
and and bugging out because
um the game is struggling to render you
because of the of the lack of
mathematical
um uh uh resolution at that level at
that distance
so where I'm going to is making a really
big space is very [__] complicated
and takes a lot of work I had a shield
why the hell would you do that for a
Skybox
yeah so the sky that's the bit I'm
struggling with okay so and it's also I
might email
um
and be like hey can we chat to somebody
and play watch this one because this is
so interesting which is like again one
of my favorite things about this game so
it is a very very big Skybox with just a
very very large planet in it there are
so many things that I don't know
that maybe even people at the studio
don't know the answer to which is like
when I went to Pluto I spawned at
Pluto's orbit so you know like you spawn
or you fast travel to a planet and then
you do the landing animation to the
planet so I spawned right in front of
Pluto flew seven hours towards Pluto and
then eventually entered Pluto and Pluto
was invisible from the inside
um yeah but that was just in Pluto's
orbit I don't know if I could fly from
Pluto's orbit to another planet I think
that those distance to Pluto
millions they are separate individual
Sky boxes and yes that distance is
millions of miles but there's nothing
saying that a it's empty it's completely
there's nothing in it except that one
big JP the sphere jpg that keeps moving
but there's nothing to say that they
aren't
falsely
massively decreasing my speed
for that particular instance of the sky
goals that make that could that could be
how you do it if the planets are much
closer than they appear
but then it wouldn't look like a spider
I'm fascinating it's one of those things
also super interested like I don't it's
a really complex messy solution to what
should be a simple if when you're
designing stuff there's two ways games
game mechanics and game stuff happens
one is a game designer sits down and
goes I want the game to be exactly like
this and then people go and make that
and another is the game designer goes I
want to make the game exactly like this
and they go make that and they realize
it's [__] and they change everything and
tweak it and iterate it and make it
something else this feels much more like
the latter like they were trying to do
it different they were trying to do
something completely different it's
entirely possible
and then decided to get rid of Landing
speculation but that would explain some
of what I'm talking about about why you
would go to that much effort for
something that doesn't actually Grant
the player
an outcome that's stable but it could
also be something else like to be clear
they never expect anyone to fly for
seven hours as part of it right like no
one so why would you make it that they
could why would they musically they knew
I'd do it like they knew someone would
do it let me summarize my problem more
why is Pluto a sphere and not just an
image of Pluto if you can't if you they
don't think you're ever gonna get close
to it
it's spinning the whole time
so every planet is always spinning as as
it should if you go to the soul system
and orbiting there might be a programmer
in the comments Who's laughing at me
because I'm massive overcome the game
but it seems like a really complex
solution that problem I really do need I
was so impressed because I was like what
why like for something no one is going
to do yeah why and there are some things
you can't access like there um there are
some like very small moons that if you
try to get close to them because they
are in a distance that's very achievable
in like a 10 minute span they will have
invisible walls around them
um
but and there's so much of it that like
and that indicates that they were trying
to block you from doing this Behavior
they did online and I'm like I don't
know which planets you can and can't and
again I've tried getting to the Sun and
I'm gonna try a couple more things
before I publish the video of my son
experiment
but realistically the sun is just going
to be like a light source that's what I
expect the sun to be is it's just going
to be bright orb
it does it'll be a sphere with a Shader
and the light source that's happening
for everything else yeah right but I I
don't think I'll ever be able to get
there I think it's too far away it's
also like
uh
it's like can I actually physically get
from Pluto to the next nearest planet
or are they locked individual Sky boxes
and can I get from one solar system to
another if I flew fast enough
because I could get to Pluto now it's
like what can't I get close to like I
don't know and I think it's true because
I can't oversay this like no man's Sky
they had to build a whole [__] engine
to do this level of calculation it's
super difficult the facts that no man's
sky is procedurally generated is one of
the reasons they can do this because you
can use seeds and anyway it's complex
but yeah you that that makes sense
whereas here this is so much work to do
to make genuinely in video games nothing
you see in most video games is ever more
than about a mile tops from you however
far it looks like it is a way it's never
further than about a mile away from you
in an open world games that's pushing
the boundaries and with some open world
games they even fake that like they will
treadmill the world around you and [__]
there's some wild stuff not so much
nowadays but like back in the GTA three
days there was a lot of [__]
happening yeah so I don't know why you
do this to get millions of miles of
space again for something that seemingly
I mean I'm only talking about four
people I was gonna say everyone assumed
wasn't even moving we assumed that we
were stuck in space Sky boxes and we
weren't even moving I assumed I was in a
space treadmill never getting closer to
a planet and then I ran into Pluto
unless you're literally moving like a
centimeter a minute and you just don't
realize it and that's that far away but
even then you would see parallaxing and
you don't want the Parallax because the
Parallax is what makes things look
things look closer if they've got
Parallax so I assume in this case
there's no Parallax I have no idea Mike
and it's fascinating it is fascinating
I'll I'll ask because there's so many
things that like
one second sorry line I'm having a
technical I'm having the technical I
thought you said you were going to take
a call and I was like right now
I mean you can I can't hear you
I'm sure it's all good
everything is fine oh hey everybody it's
just me um oh damn it I was just about
to I don't know that's a job either I'd
insult you in some way
um yeah let me see if we can get
somebody no promises obviously like I
want no shade if they they can't join us
but let me see if I can because I have
so many [__] questions and I really
feel like with the way that this works I
don't even know that everybody at bgs
would be able to answer these questions
I suspect that most people are like I
don't think so like I it I think it's so
elaborate in my head Occam's razor is
your movie you're actually only moving
like a centimeter a minute and it's just
it's putting enough speed lines around
you that it feels like you're going any
faster than that but even then I still
don't understand why you would build all
of that complexity and that's one reason
why maybe no one would want to talk to
you about but because if you're right
they have to explain trying to build
more of a I think someone may have said
that though I think Todd may have
addressed that that they
decided against letting you fly between
planets
and it was it was spoken about but it
was decided against and they just went
with the landing animation like false
drama Landing animation system and that
would explain why the system is the way
it is right but I'd obviously again
don't I don't yeah and I also don't want
to misquote him so we'll we'll see you
again I know no shade anyone if they
don't want to join I don't want to put
pressure on anyone publicly to be
interviewed by me but I'll ask
um so the final question
directly related to that I feel like we
already touched on this pretty well
um is what makes landing on planets so
complicated
why do you have to fast travel from
space to Planet surfaces like they have
separate maps and instances and this is
the one that I've answered for people
and they told me I prefer Mike Sansa
let me take a running somebody how much
why do you why is the world not
contiguous yeah why can I not just land
on the planet why have they made it a
landing animation
obviously loading times
the biggest challenge is not
necessarily A rendering one although
that would be a factor you'd have to
have some amazing outloading I mean no
man's sky does some amazing lodging and
then does a lot of like atmosphere
wiping out the screen as you as you're
Landing as well which is a clever trick
and one that I think Jedi Survivor does
for its takeoffs as well and works
really well
um
the
the actual problem is is again memory is
is that in order for a world to exist
around you it has to be in memory and
you have to load it into memory and load
it out of memory
um and the challenges there are the
scales of data so if your world's
procedurally generated again this is
this is the this is one of the things I
love about no man's sky is so many of
the problems of making a No Man's Sky
game are sold by having a randomly
general not randomly generated
procedurally generated world because and
goes to sashima as well actually used
this method which was fascinating to me
is if your world is procedurally
generated you don't have to hold
procedurally generated
for its uh for its um like for its grass
and its tree for nature stuff I know
that I believe some layer of that I
think is procedural especially
especially like grass
the reason but what about what's great
about doing anything like that procedure
is if you have to place every blade of
grass then you obviously it's it's like
your potatoes you have to store all of
the locations of all of those Blades of
grass if you have a system by which
grass is placed so it's it goes to
shimmery is not procedural to the
extender it doesn't decide on the Fly
where grass is going to be it says grass
is going to be in this area and it fills
it with grass that means you don't have
to load in during a loading screen the
position of all that grass so because
their environment is very natural that
means that all their their actual amount
of data they are loading up for like
chunks of world and that game is much
lower than you makes sense than you
would normally have for like a
Spider-Man 2 City for example like
there's a there's a drastic difference
in those problems
um but
which is why ghosty streamer has much
shorter loading times than Spider-Man
did
um the with with no man's Sky when
you're coming into a planet to land it's
not loading in where every tree is where
the valleys are where the rocks are it
knows that and can generate that on the
fly from what's going on so it's a much
so it's a you're basically loading a
piece of positional data about this
planet is here and then as you fly in
that world's being generated as it's
being lauded there's no skip of having
to ins load a bunch of stuff anyone who
played like Halo 2 back on the Xbox and
there was like that noticeable stutter
as you ran into a room where it was
loading the next room
um that's not necessary in a
procedurally generated place
if you're using an engine that's been
around since Oblivion with lots of good
updates double check that but I'm pretty
sure
but but even if we're talking about the
engine if even if this is the Skyrim
engine whatever if it's a legacy engine
that wasn't built specifically for this
and if it's not leaning on procedural
for its main city environments which it
isn't
um there's a just a phenomenal amount of
data you have to load and unload when
you're taking off or landing on the
planet because you don't want to when
you're flying off through the solar
system you don't want to be carrying all
the information about the the city you
were just in because there's no value to
that and slowing things down
which means that when you enter the app
when you turn around 180 degrees and fly
back down to the planet you have to have
that like that's so from a technical
point of view there's all of that is in
play and I would say those those are Big
Technical hurdles I would say from a
design point of view my understanding of
Starfield is
you can't [__] land anywhere you have
to land very specific places right
essentially when you land on the planet
you are landing in a in a in a city
basically online you can land anywhere
um you should we're not on the surface
of the planet yes you can um so first uh
I I was you were right I was wrong the
they used the gambrio engine for
Morrowind Oblivion and Fallout 3 and
then creation engine starting from
Skyrim so it's the
uh using Code base from Fallout 3 but I
mean even creation is
I mean all engines really work this way
so it's kind of reductive but it's it's
a a 2.0 version of gamebrio they didn't
like completely remake the engine that
would be stupid uh so it's repeated
expansions not on the same engine and
that will have created technical
challenges all languages are designed to
do a specifically there's no this is
built to make one type of game it's not
built to make sure that type of game
yeah has a very smart Frugal and game
development decision to make the game
that your engine is good at um you can
land anywhere on a planet uh you can
just pick where you want to land and go
there but generally there will be
nothing
to see and you get like a tile of a
certain amount of space
um that like I guess is like repeatedly
mapped around the planet but once you
get to the extent of the first tile like
say you've landed and you've there is a
boundary it'll tell you you have to go
back to your ship so if you want to map
out a whole planet you would have to
land find the boundary take off land
again find the boundary um so you're
getting dropped in like little places
yeah I don't know if it continues
um in that like I imagine they're not
remembering what the landscape looks
like every time you land except for if
you put an outpost down uh because that
would be absurd uh why would they let
you map out a whole planet just by
landing on the hole like I mean you can
you can fly to Pluto so maybe maybe they
are doing it that way but this the way
you would design it for this system if
you're building it is the basically the
the city biome the the location you're
meant to go to is like you know a big
map basically and then all the other
places you can go to it's usually
generating a little procedurally
generated correct square and it's not
going to and if you land in that area
again it will maybe it saves that square
maybe it doesn't doesn't really matter
but my point I think it'll save if you
put an outpost there otherwise you
wouldn't even really know how to land at
the exact same coordinates that's what
I'm saying is with the landing this
wouldn't work if that's how their
planets are set up if that they will
have hit a scope thing where they've
gone we we can make a real we can make I
don't know what it is like 20 really
good cities you can make 20. those
cities are really cool yeah yeah but
because but they don't want the
experience of you flying down from space
and you're on a blank planet flying
around looking for the little Oasis of
the city on the planet that you're meant
to be going to that would look terrible
that doesn't it's not the fantasy of the
game and it and again highlights the
limitation which is often the job of the
game development team is to steer the
player away from the the stuff where
we're saving money you know yeah it's
just so it's a lot of stuff that like my
I mean really the short answer is
to if the question was why can't you
literally what was it anymore oh why
can't we just land on planets fast
travel directly to planets
it too big like it's that's the the
short answer is it too big uh and also
just not appealing to enough people
um it it's something that I think
I I think they might have even said this
like once you do it a couple of times
that's it and then you'll be like eh I
don't wanna I'm just a fast travel it's
it and it's a phenomenally expensive
thing to get right and it's super
difficult from an art perspective from a
code perspective the the thing I think a
lot of players are unaware of them they
shouldn't be it's it's not reasonable to
expect them to be is is
bigness
impacts like file size and memory but
density is is just as important so if
you're making big randomly generated no
man's Sky planets great that's very
cheap to to load because you can just
load the seed and then generate
everything else on the fly but if you're
loading a AAA City
um that's orders of magnitude bigger in
terms of like the amount of data that
represents that versus versus that and
that's a trade-off developers make we
are we are and it's literally called
budgeting it's in terms of like how you
build this stuff out you not just not
just the financial budgeting of making
those assets but the budgeting of what
can the computer render in 30 FPS yeah
like that status that is always the
thing that we're thinking about just
constant trade-offs have you played
Boulder Skate 3
I still haven't known because they've
also done some [__] like similarly to
Starfield that I'm just like I don't
know how you did that
like
the amount of
I guess memory
no no I'm not using that word in the
technical maybe I am memory that the
characters have
is from everything I've played
unparalleled they will remember
everything you've said and you can kill
one of them and every other one will
react like there seems to be so little
limit
on
how the characters will remember your
actions and what your party has done
with however many comments like I
I can't even fathom
how they did that and thankfully I am
having some of the writers from balls
Gate 3 on my uh writing podcast because
I'm like listen to them I'm gonna be
like how the [__] did you do this sounds
like like it sounds almost like
um like like what Hades did but like in
a ridiculous scale that kind of very
very reactive stuff nuts because like
there's limits even in Starfield where
if someone's important to a quest you
just can't shoot them sure and like I've
had some moments where I've talked
somebody out of combat and be like true
so it's not we won't fight and then I
wanted to kill them anyway and couldn't
um because like I had made the verbal
decision in the dialogue tree that I was
not going to kill them
um or there's a character who can die
that if they don't die they then have to
leave for important reasons and
disappear anyway so you can kind of not
have to right probably yeah but so many
people get three games doesn't do that
it's just like I need to and I don't
it's so important you need to talk to
the writers I've got some I've got some
mates who um who were voice actors on
that I need to ask them like what the vo
sessions were like well I'm also having
uh two of the voice actors on my voice
acting podcast myself all this gate
three this is all just stuck in
scheduling right now so hopefully we'll
figure it out soon but the next two of
those podcasts are both both Baldur's
Gate 3 theme and for the same reason the
voice acting half I want to be like how
long how do you track a character yeah
you're doing all of those variations
I've spoken to people about stuff like
that before like when I had Roger Clark
on talk about Arthur you know like
Rockstar records for so long
um for Red Dead Redemption 2. it's like
I think you did like six years if I
remember correctly and even then I was
like how do you track that but then
Baldur's Gate 3 you add just so many
possibilities and outcomes like I don't
even
it's just that you should play that game
it is unbelievable it's like I want to
break my heart because I'll never be
able to do anything if you use this
something that I'm like how the [__] and
it feels cool that this year there are
two of them uh Baldur's Gate three
like Starfield is more like what have
they done here and why where Baldur's
Gate 3 is literally how the [__] did you
do that and it works so it has solid
performance it gets so impressive it's
really really cool they did a fantastic
job um on that note Mike thank you for
answering my questions
there might even be more as we dig
further into
Starfield I don't know I'm not done with
it yet I'm still going on you're saying
people should like And subscribe like
And subscribe comment uh hit that Bell
hit that Bell do people still hit Bells
I would never ask anybody to hit the
Bell who wants a notification for
everything I post yeah what an insane
thing to ask of people you don't need
that just wait until it comes up in your
feed it's fine you know I'm not gonna
ask you to subscribe to my every post
Jesus
there's no way
um all right everybody I'm Alana I'm a
video game writer That's Mike bipple
he's a video game director and this is
player watch listen we will see you next
week maybe
it's just permanently a maybe now uh
Austin is
in a recording session allegedly so he
wasn't able to join us today
um but hopefully next week we'll see bye
everyone
[Music]